PROFESSOR: Software
that implements
modern numerical methods
has two features that
aren't present in codes like
ODE4 and classical Runge-Kutta.
The methods in the software
can estimate error and provide
automatic step size control.
You don't specify
the step size h.
You specify an
accuracy you want.
And the methods
estimate the errors
as they go along and adjust
the step size accordingly.
And they provide
a fully accurate
continuous interpolant.
They don't just
provide the solution
at the discrete set of points.
They provide a function that
defines the solution everywhere
in the interval.
And so you can plot it,
find zeroes of the function,
provide a facility called
event handling, and so on.
Larry Shampine is an authority
on the numerical solution
of ordinary
differential equations.
He is the principal
author of this textbook
about solving ODEs with MATLAB.
He's a, now, emeritus professor
at the Southern Methodist
University in Dallas.
And he's been a long time
consultant to the MathWorks
about the development
of our ODE Suite.
Shampine and his student,
Przemyslaw Bogacki,
published this method in 1989.
And it's the basis
for ODE23, the first
of the methods we will use
out of the MATLAB ODE Suite.
The basic method is order three.
And the error estimate is
based on the difference
between the order three method
and then the underlying order
two method.
There are four slopes involved.
The first one is the
value of the function
at the start of the interval.
But that's based on
something called FSAL,
first same as last, where
that slope is most likely
left over from
the previous step.
If the previous
step was successful,
this function value is the
same as the last function
value from the previous step.
That slope is used to step into
the middle of the interval,
function is evaluated there.
That slope is used to
step 3/4 of the way
across the interval and a
third slope obtained there.
Then these three values
are used to take the step.
yn plus 1 is a
linear combination
of these three function values.
Then the function is evaluated
to get a fourth slope
at the end of the interval.
And then, these four slopes
are used to estimate the error.
The error estimate here is the
difference between yn plus 1
and another estimate
of the solution
that's obtained from
a second order method
that we don't actually evaluate.
We just need the difference
between that method and yn
plus 1 to estimate the error.
This estimated error is compared
with a user-supplied tolerance.
If the estimated error
is less than a tolerance,
then the step is successful.
And this fourth
slope, s4, becomes
the s1 of the next step.
If the answer is bigger
than the tolerance,
then the error
could be the basis
for adjusting the step size.
In either case,
the error estimate
is the basis for adjusting the
step size for the next step.
This is the Bogacki-Shampine
Order 3(2) Method
that's the basis for ODE 23.
Let's look at some very simple
uses of ODE23 just to get
started.
I'm going to take the
differential equation
y prime is equal to y.
So I'm going to
compute e to the t.
And just call ODE23 on
the interval from 0 to 1,
with initial value 1.
No output arguments.
If I call it ODE23, it
just plots the solution.
Here it is.
It just produces a plot.
It picks a step size,
goes from 0 to 1,
and here it gets the final
value of e-- 2.7 something.
If I do supply output arguments.
I say t comma y equals
ODE23, it comes back
with values of t and y.
ODE23 picks the
values of t it wants.
This is a trivial problem.
It ends up picking
a step size of 0.1.
After it gets started, it
chooses an initial step size
of .08 for whatever
error tolerances.
And the final value of y is
2.718, which is the value of e.
So these are the two
simple uses of ODE23.
If you don't supply any output
arguments, it draws a graph.
If you do supply output
arguments, t and y,
it comes back with
the values of t and y
choosing the values of
t to meet the error.
The default error tolerances
is 10 to the minus 3.
So this value is going to
be accurate to three digits.
And sure enough
that's what we got.
Now let's try
something a little more
challenging to see the automatic
error-controlled step size
choice in action.
Set a equal to a quarter.
And then set y0 equal to 15.9.
If I would set it to 16,
which is 1 over a squared,
I'd run into a singularity.
Now the differential
equation is y
prime is equal to 2 (a
minus t) times y squared.
I'm going to integrate this
with the ODE23 on the interval
from 0 to 1 starting at y0, and
saving the results in t and y,
and then plotting them.
So here's my plot command,
and there is the solution.
So there is a near
singularity at a.
It nearly blows up.
And then it settles back down.
So the points are
bunched together
as you go up to the
singularity and come back down,
but then get farther apart
as the solution settles down.
And the ODE solver is
able to take bigger steps.
To see what steps
were actually taken,
let's compute the difference
of t, and then plot that.
So here are the step
sizes that were taken.
And we see that
a small step size
was taken near the almost
singularity at that 0.25.
And then as we get towards
the end of the interval,
a larger step size is taken.
And then, finally,
the step size just
to reach the end of the interval
is taken as the last step.
So that's the automatic
step size choice of ODE23.
BS23 has a nice
natural interpolant
that goes along with
it that's actually
been known for over 100 years.
It's called Hermite
Cubic Interpolation.
We know that two points
determine a straight line.
Well, two points and two
slopes determine a cubic.
On each interval we have the
values of y and yn plus 1.
We also have two
slopes, namely this.
We have the derivatives at the
end points, yn prime and yn
plus 1 prime, that's the
values of the differential
equation at those points.
So those four values
determine a cubic
that goes through
those two points
and has those two slopes.
This cubic allows the software
to evaluate the solution
at any point in the interval
without additional cost
as defined by addition
evaluations of the function f.
This can be used to draw
graphs of the solution,
nice smooth graphs
of the solution,
find zeroes of the solution,
do event handling, and so on.
Another feature
provided by ODE23.